hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on phone okay and today
we're gonna be talking about how to get
the event loot the fastest and of course
in the new event for season 11 the wrath
of your man Gunderson's I was like three
you could do enjoy and let's get started
so real quick I do want to apologize I
completely forgot that there's like five
days left in this event probably should
have put this out the day after it went
live but I just completely forgot and I
woke up Saturday thinking that the event
has only been going on for a couple days
and not like a couple weeks so that's
probably why this video is going to be
out of course a little bit later then it
should be I believe I'm recording this
Saturday so and it's probably going to
be going up Sunday once again I do
apologize this will still help you for
the next like three or four days that
this is going on and and of course at
the time that I'm making this there's an
extra Lou fest so that'll be cool too
well hopefully you guys have gotten your
stuff ready but if you need a little bit
extra help that's what this video is
here for but yeah as always the number
one fastest way to get the best of Lou
in any event is always going to be
arcade
alright this arcade this time around is
actually not too bad I managed to do
this with gladiator who usually isn't
the greatest at doing teamfights but
managed to do pretty well this time the
first fight you have three shinobi's I
believe you have to fight the two of
them are basically the exact same with
bleeding health bars and stuff and the
other one just has a giant shield you
can really just run to the very corner
as you'll see in the gameplay as I try
to get away from the shinobi so they
start dying a bleed quicker so that
that's just kind of the way that I did
it then after that it's just the
standard one-on-one shinobi fight after
that you go to a warden who's all of his
attacks are uninterruptible at once
again it's a very simple one-on-one duel
you just have to remember that you can't
like proc him out of his hyper armor
because it's going to have it the entire
time other than that it's very simple he
could still of course be guard broken so
if he does like a shoulder bash you can
always dodge to the side and guard break
he will usually fall for that stuff so
really not a big deal either way third
one was a bit tricky there's two
shaolin's with I believe a shield of
health that if you don't hit them they
actually breach in and on top of that I
believe they're also uninterruptible
some something along those lines that
one was a bit tricky but I managed to
somehow barely swing by and just grab it
it's pretty interesting I actually
believe it's your character who has the
uninterruptible stance and stuff so you
can knock them out of
remove and you have a lot of hyper armor
if you're playing JJ this shouldn't be
too big of an issue and if you have
multiple heavy combos this shouldn't
also be an issue either but what
gladiator really not having the best of
combos it was a little bit of a a bit of
a hard fight but I managed to clutch it
up and pretty much do a first try and
then the last one is super straight and
very simple and there's three enemies
two Valkyries in warned shaman all you
have to do is fight the shaman so
honestly I would just lock on to the
shaman the whole time and then basically
block the Valkyries or parried the
Valkyries and stuff so that you could
get your revenge that you could go right
after the shaman I ended up clearing it
within like a couple seconds honestly
wasn't that too big of a deal once the
revenge proc so once again honestly this
entire this last week of the event is
really not that hard and this should be
an easy way to get a lot of different
stuff for your characters but obviously
comes the question what if we don't have
our kata understand if people don't want
to spend thirty dollars for a game mode
I can totally understand that now
obviously if you don't want to play
arcade I would recommend doing your
favorite game mode because honestly at
that point it's really all the same it's
all based on time now if you play three
brawl matches that's roughly equivalent
to about a Dominion game and you'll most
likely get about the same exact rewards
anyway it's just one is just taking a
little bit longer than the other that
being Dominion taking longer and
sometimes the brawl you might not
actually get as many rewards it's really
based off its sometimes based off of
time so you would think that breach
would give you the most but honestly
breach really doesn't give a whole keep
more compared to the other game modes so
honestly Dominion AI is completely fine
if you want to play the new event that's
fine too just do remember that if you
are trying to get the loot and you want
to get weapon parts that you have to
play that specific character to get the
weapon parts and if you're just trying
to get like the effect the give the
battle outfit etc that you can play any
character that you want cuz it's always
going to be random you see a quick recap
like I said if you don't have arcade
then you want to really just play your
favorite game mode dominion AI always
works pretty well it's a very fast game
mode and it's also changing up a little
bit it's not like a long breech game but
it's not too quickly brawl so actually
get rewards but if you do have like
arcade I highly recommend you doing it
especially since they updated arcade
recently to worry now you don't need a
rep 7 character with teal your score you
now just need a rep 5 with gold so you
can do this actually for a handful of
characters depending on how high your
rep is hey guys as always like the V if
you do enjoy subscribe Rafi new I
covered the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
they here update the patches in the
leaks if you want to be kept up today
with everything happened to him the
world of foreigner and never miss Ellen
update every stay subscribe the channel
and the guys take care have a great
today apologies for this video being out
a little bit later than it should have
been and take care guys have a great
Easter day
[Music]
[Music]
you